whapoosh
*shaking*
*drinks chug jug*
SKRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRA
HOOO
WAA HOO
Welcome everyone to Skrattar Du Förlorar Du© ! The rule is simple:
*demonetized crying*
I think I ran out of intros. I don't what to do. *laughs*
Now, let's just?
"JUMP IN TO IT"
That's right kids, that's what we do for here on this channel.
Has T series beat us yet?
First of all: round of applause 👏 👏
I thought it was the end game last week, but we're still in it and we're still kicking it!
Now, I'm a day ahead now - just a day ahead -
so it would be very awkward while I make this video very happy and very
cheerful, and then somehow t series has passed out of nowhere
I mean they'r- they're calling in the cavalry and all kinds of-
all these Indian celebrities going:
"Hey, I'm not paid to do this and I'm not paid to say this
but uH, subscribe to t-series
Oh and there's definitely NOT a gun to my head. But uh- subscribe to t-series."
Look at this:
"You can make India win"
I DON'T CARE!
They're calling the Indian celebrities!
P a t h e t i c
Ok? I barely relied on help from anYONE!
Now, this got a little sidetracked
We're supposed to laugh at memes but yeah, ok.
Let's just jump into it.
Ok,
WARNING, GUYS! WARNING!
Captain Marvel
spoilers coming right up.
if you haven't-
*disgusting noises*
(can't understand her)
*wheeze followed by laughter*
Ricardo. Ricardo.
I've never seen so many people being pissed off about me rating a meme.
10 OUT OF 10
It is the meme that keeps giving! I absolutely love it. Ricardo lives forever *heck yeah*
Ricardo: Immortal
The immortal son of the immortal God
Ricardo.
His name will echo ins for centuries and above.
Next meme. This is getting weird
We have already shown this but it's a
RICARDO mEME AND IT SO GODAMN BEAUTIFUL
*Laughs and loses*
Take my heart Ricardo, take it its y- its yours ❤
You gotta legit put a bar here like, anything with Ricardo gets demonetized if you show his  d o n g
So I apologize for that, by the way, that was a note for my editor, but you deserve to know
She's answering effing- she's effing answering the phones at Walmart
Woman: No, I don't work here
But the phone's ringing and ringing and I know how it feels to be on that other end and nobody answers
tEH- heheh
*distant voice*
look at that girl in the background
Woman: Uh, you're welcome. Have a good night, bye.
Owwww...
*cameraman and Felix laughing*
IT RINGS AGAIN!
*skratta-ring hard*
*cameraman literally dying*
That's kind of sweet. I like that
WALMART!
We need to find whoever's responsible (wild ricardo milos appears)
"When you definitely heard a noise in your house, but you're too afraid to turn around and look"
w h e e z e
Turn any sad day to a happy one, look at that dog. It's absolutely terrified. Okay, I've shown this clip, right?
I feel like I have-
Man: I'm checking out Finley's I
Think it was supposed to be
in the uh
Ken's reddit video, but I think we got cut out but it's so good, so basically,  he's looking at is 8 year old
Sons- history
*man reading his history*
Arson,
Arson???
Ubisoft. Okay,
Man: Fortnite... (cant understand it)
Oh?
Man: Barbecue sauce on titties :D
*everyone laughs*
B I G I N H A L E
Camerawoman: Barbecue sauce on titties :)
*she laughs*
Man with a higher pitched voice:
sO IM SIttinG TheRE. BARBEC UE S AA UCE ON MA TITTIES
look
what? Is that on youtube?
*this is just too funny, guys*
Feel like that could be me here's- I feel bad for this eight-year-old Poland brother
He doesn't deserve this ridicule that will follow him for the rest of his life
I just realized I haven't had the green-screen film. What the hell is this? Oh
*old pewdiepie scream*
w a i t
oh my  g o d
Very nice moving on. Have you lost the challenge ye-? Oh my god. I haven't even been paying attention to my health bar this is-
*Drinks sheild potion
Looks like I'm fine. Have you ordered your G-fuel?
By the way enter the code pewdiepie to get 10% off pretty good deal moving on. No you
Stupid he's not mad. It's not mad. If it was mad, you know, he would have won. That's right
Well, you never looked at your own face just the ultime mean where this would have been if we pulled out a mirror
Yes, sir. Just a little feedback for the future moving on looks like we're off to the west coast to find some more League
Let's see what we can find
Phil
What are you doing in Minecraft sweat fairly Swift be back later?
Damn bill is living the high life
Did you guys see this flex seal did their farm sub - PewDiePie?
Phil Swift declares that in order to assist PT pi
He will saw T Series in half Thank You. Phil. Sweet. Very cool
Oh my god
I
Don't know what that one not a skeptic from me. At least. I'm sorry
Try next time maybe but it turns out I am undefeated in this challenge obscure do feel already. I just can't lose. It's crazy
Peter PI versus two series ahead
No car needs a new code in its cosmic our goddamn right cuz konoka
Terminal, mr. Lee. What is T Sarah, Nicole?
Oh
My god, yeah
Holy shit, oh my god
Absolutely, beautiful and that makes everything worth it. That's hilarious. Goddamn it
How do I look like okay, okay Selena Gomez I
Mean both human good joke Felix. Thank you next meme everyone
Check
What happens over black culture to another level
See this wave son
Crazy
Good meme man, we had some good laughs today, don't we?
God damn it. Oh god. I said it kids go. I've got are they gonna add another layer?
Now this is the kind of real enthusiasm when I asked for a broker
Just kidding. You broke your screen for nothing
How is your screen not broken yet pounded real for once final give me your orders broke fit ah
Ah
Damn that feels good. I'll buy you a new monitor Cyril. I'm sorry
Into the mouth was beautiful
Into the now
Nice
This is great. It just makes me smile. Good thing. This isn't try not just my own challenge
What does he see
RICARDOOOOOOOO!!!!
Hell yeah, Ricardooo I love him
Spirit home. I see home
God damn, what's with the Swedish?
crossover under Ricardo means like baktun Anna and then now they played
I've obviously I have we can't show the audio play here. It's me. I don't look this. That's it for me for now
Hope you guys enjoyed this episode smash like subscribe and it always this is not the real merch guys
This is not the merch you have to buy this is the verge
I know it's a bit disappointing compared to but, okay
This is the new Burch check in a hug and I see you guys borrow a bike.
What?
Tuber simulators becoming relevant
No, no, don't leave
No please, sponsor eagle. Please do something!
Yes, yeah!
Aahh...
This game is still relevant, god damnit!